عقوبات اوروبيه وامريكيه جديده على روسيا
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا
كيف تقول ان روسيا ضاعفت سفنها في البحر
الاسود ولا تستبعد مزيدا من الضربات
الصاروخيه
واعتقاله محمد مجري احد ابرز ممولين
ميليشيا حزب الله اللبناني لدى وصوله الى
مطار بوخارست
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الاهم الانباء من
العربي اعلنت رئاسه السويديه لمجلس
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان التكتل وافق على حزمه
عقوبات جديده على روسيا في الذكرى السنويه
الاولى لغزو اوكرانيا الحزمه الاوروبيه
العاشره منذ بدء الحرب تشمل قيودا موجهه
ضد افراد وكيانات داعمه للحرب وتنشر
الدعايه او تسلم طائرات مسيره تستخدمها
روسيا في الحرب
وكانت واشنطن اعلنت بدورها عن حزمه عقوبات
جديده على موسكو وقالت وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه نواشنطن استهدفت شركات وافرادا
روسا في قطاعات المعادن والمناجم والمعدات
العسكريه واشباه الموصلات اضافه الى 30
فردا وشركه في دول اوروبيه متهمين
بالمساعده في الالتفاف على العقوبات
ميدانيا قال الجيش الاوكراني لروسيا ضعفت
عدد السفن العامله في البحر الاسود
وتوقع ان يكون ذلك استعدادا لمزيد من
الضربات الصاروخيه وتطلق البحريه الروسيه
على نحو متكرر صواريخ من اسطولها في البحر
الاسود في اطار مسعى موسكو لاستهداف
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه الاوكرانيه ومنشات
توليد الطاقه ويتمركز اسطول روسيا في
البحر الاسود في شبه جزيره القرم التي
ضمتها موسكو في 2014
في غضون ذلك نقلت صحيفه وولز جورنال عن
مسؤولين قولهم ان المانيا وفرنسا ابلغت
زينينسكي بضروره الاخذ بالاعتبار مفاوضات
السلام واشارت الصحيفه بحسب المسؤولين الى
ان النيتو يرى ان اقامه علاقه قويه مع
اوكرانيا يشجعها على السلام فيما نقلت
صحيفه عن مسؤول فرنسي قوله بانه اذا
استمرت الحرب لمده اطول فان خسائر
اوكرانيا ستكون هائله وحذر الرسول الفرنسي
كيف بانها لن تكون قادره على استعاده
القرب
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس
كليبرلي في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه ان
مبادره السلام صينيه في اوكرانيا تضم بعض
العناصر المهمه كمعارضه استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه وكذلك دعم ميثاق الامم المتحده
مضيفا انه غير مقتنع بكون الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يريد السلامه
اننا ننظر الى الوثائق التي قدمها
الصينيون وتضم بعض العناصر الهامه
كمعارضتهم لاستعمال الاسلحه النوويه ودعم
ميثاق الامم المتحده سننظر الى هذه
الوثيقه بكل جديه اتمنى ان تنتبه القياده
الروسيه للحقيقه وهي ان العالم يدين
تصرفاتها ولا يريد الحرب امل ان تكون هذه
الخطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح لست مقتنعا ان
فلاديمير بوتين يريد السلام يجب ان ندعم
اوكرانيا الى ان تستعد اراضيها
خطه السلام الصينيه في اوكرانيا تقوم على
12 نقطه في مقدمتها تطبيق مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده الخاصه باحترام سياده الدول
وعدم استخدام القوه والتهديد بها لضم
الاراضي ونبذو عقليه الحرب البارده هو عدم
السعي لتحقيق الامن القومي على حساب امن
الدول الاخرى والاهتمام بالمشاكل الامنيه
لكافه دول اوروبا الخطه ترتكز ايضا على
وقف القتال والصراع والتحلي بضبط النفس
تفاديا لتاجيج النزاع مع اطلاق مفاوضات
سلام وفتح باب الحل السياسي في اسرع وقت
ممكن الازمه الانسانيه لها حيز من الخطه
عبر دعم وتشجيع كافه الاجراءات التي تساهم
في تخفيف ازمه المدنيين وحمايه الاسرى
الخطه تدعو ايضا للحفاظ على سلامه المحطات
النوويه والتقليل من المخاطر الاستراتيجيه
من خلال معارضه استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والك
والبيولوجيه خارطه الطريق الصينيه تدعو
لضمان نقل الحبوب وتنفيذ مبادره البحر
الاسود وكذلك بالتوقف عن فرض العقوبات
احاديه الجانب مع ضمان استقلال سلاسل
الصناعه والامداد والحفاظ على النظام
الاقتصادي العالمي القائم لتخلص الخطه
لدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى الدفع باعاده
الاعمار بعد نهايه النزاع بلال البجدين
العربيه
متصل بالازمه اعلنت واشنطن انها لم ترصد
اي تغييرات في تكوين القوات النوويه
الروسيه بعد قرار موسكو تعليق مشاركتها في
معاهده
الدفاع الامريكيه
ان الولايات المتحده لم ترصد اي تغييرات
في تكوين القوات النوويه الروسيه بعد
تعليق المشاركه في معاهده الحد من الاسلحه
الهجوميه الاستراتيجيه
وفي مقابله مع قناه العربيه اعتبر جون
بولتون مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق ان افضل وسيله لمنع روسيا من
استخدام سلاح النووي هي الرد روبوتين
فيما يخص بوتين نحن لا نريد ان تستخدم
روسيا الاسلحه النوويه والسؤال المطروح ما
هي اكثر السبل فعاليه لردع روسيا من
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه في الصراع في
اوكرانيا بوتين هو قائد القوات المسلحه
وهو هدف عسكري مشروع ويجب ان اوضح ذلك ان
كان هناك شخص لديه فكره افضل لردع روسيا
من استخدام السلاح النووي فسيسرني
الاستماع اليها ولكن جذب انتباه بوتين هو
افضل سبيل في وجهه نظري
بين التكتيك هو الاستراتيجيه كثيره كانت
التحركات العسكريه على الجبهات الاوكرانيه
بدا الروس حربهم ب 190 الف جندي كانوا
وقود المعارك المشتعله قبل الاضطرار
لاعاده تعبئه الجزئيه في اكتوبر الماضي
ليصل عددهم الى 220 الفا واليوم تشير
التقديرات الى 330 الف عنصر بين جنود
وقوات انفصاليه ومتطوعين ومرتزقه كيف كانت
تحركات طوال السنه الاولى من الحرب
الاجابه مع زميله حنين
عمل طويل لدى بوتين واطول منه لدى
الاوكرانيين وبنهايته ابتعدت جدا احلام
العوده الى الشهر الاول من الحرب
الاوكرانيه الرابعه عشر من مارس روسيا
تستولي على 27% من اوكرانيا اكثر من ربع
البلاد من الجنوب بمساحته الزراعيه
الشاسعه وتحديدا في خرسون الى الشمال محطه
شرنوبل وممر بري يصل الى حافه كييف كانت
هذه ذروه النجاح الروسي ومن قمته جاء
السقوط الحر في ابريل الى قاع الفشل على
ابواب العاصمه الاوكرانيه انسحب الروس من
شمال وشمال شرق اوكرانيا في الثامن من
ابريل لتبدا المرحله الثانيه كما اسمها
بوتين بخساره اربعين في المئه من مكاسب
الميدان من مايو وحتى نهايه اغسطس خطوات
بطيئه في الشرق حققت مكسبي ماريوبول نهايه
مايو ولوجانسك
لم يستشعر بوتين في غمار محاوله جيشه
السيطره على دنياتك العاصفه القادمه من
خارقيب العاشر من سبتمبر اكبر تقدم للجيش
الاوكراني في يوم واحد على حساب انسحاب
الروس في الشمال الشرقي باكثر من 50
كيلومترا والمساحه تحمل اهميتها انسحب
الجيش الروسي من مدينتيوم وكوبيانس
المركزين اللوجستيين اليدومباس في اسبوع
واحد فقط من الهجوم المضاد كانت المكاسب
الاوكرانيه من الاراضي اكبر مما استولت
عليه القوات الروسيه في الاشهر الخمسه
الماضيه هل يعني ذلك ان روسيا تخسر الحرب
لا الضمه اللي اربع مقاطعات انقذها
واكسبها وسته عشر الف كيلو مترا مربع طبعا
مع القرم ونتحدث هنا عن مساحه دوله بحجم
بلغاريا
غير ان المكسب او ربعه لم يدم طويلا في
العاشر من نوفمبر تنسحب القوات الروسيه من
خرسون وهي اول مقاطعه سقطت تحت السيطره
الروس تخليها مع محيطها على طول الضفه
الغربيه لنهر دينيبرو موسكو سحبت اربعين
الف جنديا من المنطقه
باستعاده خرسون تواجد اوكرانيا مكاسبها من
هجومها المضاد مسترجعه
من اراضيها لكن الحرب رمال متحركه في
الخامس والعشرين من يناير الماضي القوات
الاوكرانيه تنسحب من سوليدار شرقا بعد
اقتحام قوه المعادله العسكريه الروسيه
بقوه وتصدرها مشهد الحرب في اعقاب التباطؤ
الشتوي المكسب مهم سوليدار بدرجه اقل
المكسب الحقيقي على بعد عشره كيلو مترات
ولاجله سجلت اكثر المعارك دمويه في الحرب
محمود في دنيا هي الحصن على حد وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني
والبوابه الوحيده للروس في تقدم سيطرتهم
على المقاطعه الانفصاليه محمود تفتح
الطريق نحو مدينه
الرئيسيتين تشكلان مع مقاطعتي
الكبير في اوكرانيا
بكلمات مؤثره تحدث الرئيس
الاوكرنسكي عن علاقته بعائلته خلال الحرب
حيث اعرب عن حبه الكبير لزوجته وابنائه عن
اشتياق الكبير اللهم
السؤال الاخير والاصعب احبهم زوجتي ومن كل
قلبي اطفالي هم اهم الناس بالنسبه لي لا
اراهم كثيرا ولدايه لاراهم نهائيا
انا فخور جدا بزوجتي واعتقد انها تفعل كل
شيء من اجلنا اعرفوا اي نوع من الاشخاص
فهي تفعل كل شيء من اجل الاطفال والبلد
وفي مقابله مع العربيه كشف مقاتل في الجيش
الاوكراني كواليس القتال في جبهه المعركه
مبرزا تفاصيل مواجهات مباشره مع القوات
الروسيه وعناصر قوات باجنار والقوات
الشيشانيه التابعه لقادير
[موسيقى]
شاركت في القتال من تلقاء نفسي وتفوقنا
على الجنود الروس بشكل كبير لقد هربوا منا
وتركوا الاسلحه حتى ظننا اننا في نهايه
الحرب هربوا من كياف ثم بخموت وخيرسون لا
افهم كيف ولكن ان عادوا سنطلق عليهما
النار لن نترك احدا منهم على قيد الحياه
عندما تراجعوا لمن يهاجم وتركوا الاسلحه
وهربوا الى الغابات واختباوا ولم يعودوا
رايت مقاتل فاغنر وقادر وجنود الروس حتى
جنود المخابرات الروسيه والفرق الخاصه
تميز بالقسوه لكن كنا اقوى حينما وصلنا
كان كل شيء مدمرا اتينا لنلبي نداء
الطبيعه
الوطن قام بمنادتنا لم نكن نريد ان نقتل
اي احد هم اتوا ليقتلون ولكن قتلناهم في
البدايه لم نخسر الكثير من جنودنا ومع
استمرار القتال في بخموت خسرنا الكثير
في مقابله خاصه للعربيه ان الولايات
المتحده لديها اكثر من عشره الاف جندي
يقفون جنبا الى جنب مع القوات البولنديه
لحفظ الامن
لدينا اكثر من عشره الاف عسكري في بولندا
يقفون الى جانب قوات البولنديه نحن نقيم
التهديدات والاوضاع لنرى مستوى الوضع
العسكري ومدى جاهزيه القوات ناقشنا الوضع
العسكري وكيف يمكن القيام بكل شيء كي يكون
كل طرف منا امنا
تتابعنا ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
كرم المرعش تزيح غبار الركام رويدا رويدا
وتفتح جزئيا محلها واسواقها
اهلا بكم من جديد
اعتقلت شرطه رومانيه محمد ابراهيم بزير
الذي صنفته الولايات المتحده على لائحه
الارهاب في عام 2018
وعرضت وقتها عشره ملايين دولار مكافاه
ماليه للحصول على معلومات حول مكان وجوده
وتم القاء القبض على الذي يتهم بتحويل
ملايين الدولارات الى حزب الله اللبناني
على مر سنوات لدى وصوله الى مطار بوخارست
الايرانيه باحتماليه بيع طهران رادارات
وصواريخ ارض جو الى دمشق وذلك لمساعدتها
في تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه لمواجهه ضربات
الجويه الاسرائيليه المتكرره ونشرت هيئه
الاذاعه الحكوميه الايرانيه ان سوريا
بحاجه لاعاده بناء شبكه دفاعها الجوي كما
تتطلب او تطلب قنابل دقيقه
لطائراتها المقاتله
اخريه في ايران طالب زعيم البلوشي السلطات
الايرانيه بالاستماع لمطالب المحتجين او
التنحي عن السلطه فيما ردد متظاهرون
شعارات مناهضه للحكومه رغم الانتشار
الامني وحجب الانترنت واظهرت لقطات باثاها
ناشطون محتجين وسط مدينه زيدان يرددون
شعارات بينها الموت للديكتاتور
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء قالت منظمه العفو الدوليه ان
هناك ادله تؤكد وفاه متظاهرين من اقليه
بسبب الضرب المبرح اثناء احتجاجه بمركز
شرطه مدينه زاهدان جنوب شرق ايران قالت
المنظمه ان سلطات الايرانيه حاولت الضغط
على عائلات المتظاهر الذي يدعى ابراهيم
ريكي ويعمل طبيبا لدفنه دون تشريح جثمانه
وقدمت معلومات متناقضه للتهرب من
المسؤوليه ونقل موقع ايران انترناشونال ان
ابراهيم ريكي كان اعتقل في وقت سابق بسبب
تقديمه
للعلاج لبعض المتظاهرين قبل ان يتم
الافراج عنه فيما بعد
[موسيقى]
انفجارات او انفجارات تهز طهران من شرقها
الى غربها منذ اقل من شهر وهذه المره وقع
انفجار وسط المنطقه العسكريه للنظام
الايراني في مدينه
بعد اقل من شهر على انفجار اصفهان الذي
وقع في منشاه عسكريه ايرانيه انفجار اخر
غربي العاصمه تهران ونيران المضادات
الجويه تتصدى في مدينه كرنج
الانفجار ناجم عن هجوم بواسطه مسيره
استهدفت سياره بالقرب من حديقه عظيميه في
مدينه كرج
اترجيحات قالت ان السياره كان يستخدمها
حامد عبد الله قائد الوحده 400 اهم وحده
في فيلق القدس وهي الوحده المسؤوله عن دعم
الميليشيات المواليه لايران ماليا وعسكريا
وفق مصادر مطلعه اكدت مقتل شخصين بعد توجه
السيارات اسعاف الى موقع الانفجار اما
طهران فقالت ان اطلاق النار ناتج عن
مناوره لقوات الباسج الامر عينه سبق
لايران ان اعلنته بعد هجمات وتفجيرات
سابقه مماثله لتتراجع بعد فتره وتؤكد وقوع
مدينه كارج مليئه بمواقع وانفاق عسكريه
تحت الارض كما توجد فيها عده مواقع
اتصالات ورضارات مركز القياده للدفاع
الايراني وفكونات تابعه للحرس الثوري
وزير الخارجيه احمد عوض ضامن مبارك
المجتمع الدولي لاستهداف الشبكات الماليه
لميليشيات الحوثي وبذل مزيد من الجهد
للضغط عليها مؤكدا ضروره تصنيفها جماعه
ارهابيه قال بالمبارك ان هناك ادوارا
كثيره يمكن القيام بها لدفع هذه الجماعه
الى مزيد من المرونه في التعامل مع جهود
السلام وتم التجربه هذه الضغوط في اتفاقات
سابقه ولولاها لما اتى الحوثيون الى طاوله
المشاورات واضاف الوزير اليمني انه منذ
اكتوبر الماضي استمرت الميليشيات الحوثيه
في استهداف المنشات النفطيه فاصبحت
الحكومه اليمنيه غير قادره على تصدير
باستهداف
في تونس قال نجلو المعارض غازي الشواشي ان
الشرطه اعتقلت والده بعد تفتيش منزله
وكانت السلطات القتل القبض على القياده
بجبهه الخلاص المعارضه جوهر من مبارك كما
اعتقلت كلا من امين عام الحزب الجمهوري
المعارض عصام شابي والقياديه بجبهه الخلاص
شيماء عيسى
وفيما اتهم الرئيس التونسي الموقوفين
بالتامر على امن الدوله وترتيب انقلاب
تقول المعارضه ان الاعتقالات الاخيره
تصفيه حساب مع الخصوم السياسيين
قال رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان فتحي باشاغه ان العام 2023
يجب ان يكون عام انتخابات شامله حره
ونزيهه تحقيقا لتطلعات شعب الليبي في
تغيير والانتقال الديمقراطي واشاد باشا
بدور الولايات المتحده في استضافه وقياده
اجتماع ممثل عدد من الدول لدعم مسار ليبيا
نحو السلام والاستقرار
كشفت وكاله نقلا عن مسؤولين محليين في
مالي عن مقتل ما لا يقل عن 13 مدنيا في
هجوم نصب الى متطرفين استهدفوا قريه في
وسط البلاد واحرق واقواخا ومخازن وغادروا
ومعهم ثلاثه مدنيين
كهرمان مرعش المدينه التي كانت مركز زلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا بدات تزيح غبار
ركاب رويدا رويدا وتعيد فتح محالها
واسواقها ولو بشكل جزئي
واصطحاله من القلق والخوف في كهرمان مرعش
اختار بعض اصحاب المحال التجاريه اعاده
افتتاح محالهم في تحد لهذا الواقع فشهدت
بعض الاسواق والازقه عوده تدريجيه للحياه
الطبيعيه
ليس ببعيد عن الركام واليات رفع الانقاض
اعاد مراد افتتاح محل بيع الهواتف
المحموله ومستلزماتها وهدفه تشجيع البقيه
ليحذوا حذوه فتحنا متجرنا منذ اليوم
الثاني للزلزال لتوفير احتياجات الناس من
ناحيه الاتصالات ومن اجل تحفيز الجميع وهو
شيء جيد بالنسبه لنا ولهم الناس عندما ترى
متجرا مفتوحا يفرحون والحياه ستستمر كما
شاهدتم المحل بدات بفتح ابوابها لكننا لم
نستطع العوده الى بيوتنا بسبب الهزات
الارتداديه اما اصحاب هذا الفرن فقرروا
اعاده افتتاح مخبزهم منذ اليوم الاول رغم
حاله الخوف الشديد حينها يعني جانبو
الجميع يخاف ومن يقول انه لا يخاف هو كاذب
ستلجا الى الله في تلك اللحظات ولا يمكنك
فعل غير ذلك علينا اتباع التعليمات اثناء
حدوث الزلزال
نحضر الخبز التقليدي الذي لا يمكن التخلي
عنه في قهرمان مرعش هذا المنتج هو
التقليدي ومحلي كما قلت منذ اليوم الاول
للزلزال نقدم خدماتنا للناس
ومع مرور الايام طوال افتتاح المحل في
الاسواق الرئيسيه في تحد لحاله الهلع
والخوف التي ما زالت سائده في المدينه
فتحنا المحل لكن الهزات الارتداديه مستمره
الناس خائفه قبل ايام حدث زلزال قوي في
هاتاي وشعرنا به هنا وانهارت بعض الابنيه
المتصدعه استطعنا بعد عشره ايام من
الزلزال الاول فتح محلنا لكننا حقيقه نخشى
الهزات الارتداديه والى الان لا نستطيع
العوده الى منازلنا ونبقى في الخيام
والشوارع والسيارات
الحياه تستمر وذكريات ما جرى لا يمكن ان
تمحى اطياف من رحلوا تحت الانقاض لا تزال
تجوب المكان ومن كتبت له النجاه ما زال
يابى النسيان يجول بين الانقاض
ويلملمم بقايا من رحلوا زيدان زنجلو
العربيه كهرمان مرعش
لا تزال قوافل مركز الملك سلمان لغاثيه
تتوافد عبر المنافق الحدوديه السوريه
لمساعده المتضررين جواز الجال حيث وصلت
اخر تلك القوافل عبر معبر الحمام قرب
جنديرس باربع واربعين شاحنه وهي الاكبر
التي تصل من المساعدات السعوديه وتتضمن
القافله التي تعد الاكبر من المساعدات
لسوريا حوالي 25 طنا من المواد الاغاثيه
المتنوعه
في الختام هذا تذكير بابرز العناوين
عقوبات اوروبيه وامريكيه جديده على روسيا
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا
كيف تقول ان روسيا ضاعفت سفنها في البحر
الاسود ولا تستبعد مزيدا من الضربات
الصاروخيه
اعتقال محمد بزي احد ابرز مموليه ميليشيا
حزب الله اللبناني لدى وصوله الى مطار
بوخارست
نهايته هذه النشره دائما المزيد على
العربيه شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]